we turn now to the war in ukraine which
grinds on after more than five months
it's been five months of fighting with
casualties rising on both sides
thousands of ukrainian soldiers have
suffered life-changing wounds but say
they are determined to continue
defending their country if possible our
holly williams visited a rehab center in
western ukraine which is trying to help
these warriors recover
ukraine's wounded warriors soldiers
who've lost limbs fighting off russia's
invasion
at this rehabilitation center in western
ukraine far from the front line they're
rebuilding their bodies and their minds
it was a big pain but
also it was a big shock
captain danilo ishchenko lost his leg
last month to a russian mortar he told
us during intense fighting
around ukraine's second city harkev i am
a warrior and
it's not very important
water with iron leg or water with
natural lag it doesn't matter if your
leg is made from metal yes flesh yes yes
you'll fight on yes i will fight he's
already learning to ride horses as part
of his therapy he says his next goal is
to complete a biathlon
major victor daeneker lost both his legs
to a russian missile on the first day of
the war back in february he told us
incredibly without adequate first aid
equipment he says he improvised a
tourniquet from his own belt to stop the
loss of blood
he's been fitted with these temporary
prosthetics
and it just snaps on like that but told
us he recently had a fool
because he was trying to move too
quickly
ukraine's military heroes are as stoical
and determined as their country but many
here are hoping that america can come to
the rescue by giving them top quality
prosthetics and world-class
rehabilitation and captain ishchenko
told us he has another motive to go to
the us i want to learn more about drones
battle drones
he wants to train to fly drones with the
american military so he can use the
weapons back home against russia
ukraine and its people are battle
scarred
but unbroken
for cbs morning's holly williams in
western ukraine
the resilience yeah it's unbelievable
and the sacrifice those two at the end
there seems so young right so innocent
and a year ago they weren't fighting
they weren't injured they were fully
able a year ago yeah everything's
changed yeah sacrifices
periods heartbreaking i